It can be so hard to forgive because – so
often – we simply are in the right and the
scale of the folly, thoughtlessness and meanness
of others seems utterly beyond our own measure.
But there are two inviolable ideas which should
nevertheless, in the face of the grossest
behavior, be kept in mind to increase our
chances of being able to forgive.
Firstly: we must remember how the other person
got there, to this place of idiocy and cruelty.
Every irritating fault in another person has
a long history behind it. They have become
like this because of flaws in their development,
which they did not choose for themselves.
They were shaped by troubles which we cannot
see but which we can know exist. The arrogant
person was trapped (at some key point in their
personal evolution) in an environment where
being modest and reasonable seemed to guarantee
they’d be trampled on. The hyper-critical
individual has lived too much, as their personality
was growing, around people who couldn’t
take a gentle hint – so they came to rely
on blunt assertions. The frustratingly timid,
mousy person was (at some stage) terrified;
the show-off learned their irritating manner
around people who were hard to please. Behind
every failing – behind everything that’s
wrong and infuriating about those we meet
– is a decisive trauma encountered before
someone could cope with it properly. They
are maddening but they got to be this way
without meaning to. To forgive is to understand
the origins of evil and cruelty. Secondly,
and very strangely, there are difficult things
about you too. Of course, not in this area.
Not in any area remotely connected to the
sort of lapses that destroy your faith in
humanity. But in some areas, quiet areas that
you forget about as soon as you’ve travelled
through them, you too are a deeply imperfect
and questionable individual. Gently, you have
– in your own way – betrayed. Nicely,
you have been a coward. Modestly, you have
forgotten your privileges. Unthinkingly, you
have added salt to the wounds of others. We
don’t need to know anything about you to
know this as a certainty. We must forgive
because – not right now, not over this,
but one day, over something – we need to
be forgiven. We would – in the past – regularly
have looked up to the heavens for this forgiveness.
We do that less and less. But that doesn’t
attenuate the need for some moments when we
limber up to utter that most implausible word
‘sorry’ – or indeed stretch our ethical
imagination in order to pronounce those even
more arduous and unnatural words, ‘I forgive you.
The School Of Life isn't just a YouTube Channel, it's an actual school where you  can go and take classes.
We have branches in ten locations around the world.  To find out more click the link on the screen now.